yeah they're making me go to this
halloween party bro my parents suck
so lame i don't even understand why they
want me to go it's outside yo
yo yo what up son hip hop
hip to the hop i like rap and i respect
the cops yeah this is racist you cannot
do this what do you mean i can't do it
lighten up snowflaking get your costume
on come on
this is 2020. do you understand all the
[ __ ] that's happened this year and now
you're dressing like this you're making
it worse you're going to cause more rice
just by going to this party got no paper
that's why you mad you ain't got no
paper
you ain't got no paper my paper's long
son my paper is [ __ ] long that's
right but it's not right this is racist
you don't get it where's your mother
where's my hope
mom what the [ __ ] i'm an engine and your
father is a hip-hop
and we're going to have fun do you
understand that enough with this pc
snowflake [ __ ] and you're going to
in a boring non-offensive costume you're
going to be a cop
[Music]
yeah man it looks like i finally got
them to switch costumes they're making
me go as a cop but it is what it is at
this point